[Music]
just weeks after Joey Fatone was
revealed to be one of the singing
celebrities in disguise on the masked
singer he's telling et he wants to be
back next season
but this time in a different way who
knows was gonna be on it and I don't
want to know who's gonna be up because
if I'm a judge on it
plug plug hopefully that would be fun
because now that I have an inside view
and coming from another standpoint be
kind of fun to do so we'll see hopefully
I'd love to foresee a lot of different
people out there even a lot more people
that maybe don't get a chance to sing
like it sounds like Rumer Willis I mean
she's saying before but not many people
knew her voice and kick-ass voice
Minister reale she's amazing it's
shaping up to be a busy year for the
singer in May he'll be hosting the 30th
anniversary of the debut episode of the
all-new Mickey Mouse Club we've actually
reached out to Ryan we reached out to
Christina which other they reach out to
Justin they reach out obviously to JC so
I know some of the most humane come out
there and do some surprises depending
but it's crazy because they have like
almost everybody else though
you got Rona you got Matt you got you
got Dale you got chase some people don't
know what I'm talking about if you're
from watch The Mickey Mouse Club like a
fan like I was and I was friends of
theirs you know what I'm talking about
so it's really great to see all these
people and actually come together and
actually the cool thing about is it's
later on after they have all the
different festivities which is gonna be
helped out I think by Megacon in Orlando
and also Disney's gonna be helping out a
little bit they're actually get together
with all the casts and like all the old
crew members and they haven't seen each
other literally in 30 years so it's
gonna be fun to kind of get all these
people go because I used to hang out
with the like I said JC and Justin and a
bunch of other cast members and Jen
McGill actually was one of the girls
that was in my high school as well that
I know from the mouse Club
those interesting to see everybody
together speaking of the old days joey
is still proudly supporting his former
NSYNC bandmates
like Lance Bass who recently produced a
documentary about Lou Perlman it's
awesome yeah it's a it gives an incident
interesting in-depth look about Lou
Pearlman because I know that MSNBC had a
and a documentary on it
which was a the green one this one gives
it and actually goes back even further
it's interesting because I didn't know a
lot of things about Lou like that
meaning when he was a kid what was his
ideas how did he come up with this howdy
this game so this whole thing is really
crazy again it really sucks at what he
did to people but then again it's one of
those tongue-in-cheek things because of
the fact that if it wasn't for him we
wouldn't be where we are today so he was
bad as a businessman great for a
visionary I think so I'm excited for but
it's great it's gonna be great
documentary you know Lance does a lot of
different things this is deadly by forum
one of the best things I've ever seen
him
[Music]